in this video we'll talk about the
principles of two photon microscopy
so we would learn the working principle
application and the components of a two
photon microscope
two photon microscope is one variant of
fluorescence microscopy that means
fluorescence light would be used for
imaging now let us appreciate what are
the variations from fluorescence
microscope
you might have already know the working
principle of a fluorescence microscope
if you missed it you can watch the video
on fluorescence microscope at any point
of time by clicking on the i button
now here is our overview
here is our excitation light
and through a filter cube the desired
wavelength is illuminating our
fluorescence specimen
and the emitted fluorescent light is
returning back through the objective
and reaching the detector
at this point of time the excitation
light allows the electron to jump into
excited state and later on it relaxes
and thereby gives us a fluorescence
emission fluorescence emission as
depicted by this green line is detected
by any kind of detector like camera
photo multiplier tube etc
now two photon microscopy is pretty much
similar with some modifications
but before understanding two photon
microscopy we should analyze the name
two photon
actually two photon is a kind of like a
process
so here is a one photon process which is
normally the understood by the zablonski
diagram so here you have excitation
light which allows the electron to jump
from ground state to excitation state
there would be vibrational relaxation
which would ultimately lead to a
radiative emission which we see as a
fluorescence this process is otherwise
known as one photon process or one
photon fluorescence emission
but there is something called two photon
or multi photon process here instead of
exciting with one particular photon
here you excite with two photons with
with an energy
which is much less so the sum of energy
is enough to excite
a electron to jump into the excitation
state
and thereby there would be a similar
kind of vibrational relaxation and
emission of fluorescence
one thing to note is
the time difference between these two
pulses
are less than 50 femtoseconds that means
they are almost coinciding with each
other and this coincidence is really
important for the fluorescence phenomena
and this is overview of two photon
process
in fluorescence microscopy
one photon fluorescence is used also in
the confocal microscopy we use the
phenomena of one photon fluorescence
whereas in two photon microscopy we use
the two photon fluorescence or
multiphoton fluorescence system
now already you get a point that how
things work so let's say we have to
excite this gfp molecule we can either
excite with a one photon process with a
light of wavelength 488 nanometer
and we can do the same with a two photon
process using a light of 920 nanometers
in wavelength so we have to give two
pulses of 920 nanometer wavelength which
are less than 50 femtosecond second
apart in order to illuminate them
but what is the advantage we can
understand the advantage by a simple
formula
so the one photon fluorescence which is
illuminating with 488 nanometer would
have very high energy compared to the
two photon process which has a lower
energy why is so because e or the energy
is equal to hc by lambda that means
simply energy is inversely proportional
to wavelength
higher the wavelength lower would be the
energy and it makes a lot of sense
because it reduces the chances of
photobleaching if we use a higher
wavelength a infrared wavelength in this
case the chances of photo bleaching
would be low but we achieve the same
phenomena of fluorescence we illuminate
the specimen it would fluoresce but the
chances of photobleaching get reduced
okay another factor is scattering so
let's say this is a tissue space this
block represents a tissue and in this
tissue there are many fluorophores at
different different levels and different
different depth
when we illuminate the fluorophores at
the surface there are not much
scattering but imagine some fluorophore
to be present in the deep inside the
tissue
then it would lead to a lot of
scattering
now there is an issue with wavelength as
well scattering is also inversely
proportional to lambda to the power 4
that means greater the wavelength
lesser would be the scattering and
that's why in a two photon process if we
use a 920 nanometer wavelength we would
have lesser scattering compared to if we
use a 488 nanometer wavelength so these
are the two important factors that gives
two photon an added advantage from other
one photon processes
now let us talk talk about the
comparison between these all microscopic
uh kind of principles
so let's say in a cuvette you have
fluorescent dye if we illuminate the
cuvette with an objective and do it by
wide field fluorescence microscope you
would see a wide
illumination beam like this
if we do it for a confocal microscope
the beam would be much narrower because
the laser is coherent and the laser
waste is narrow but still there would be
some amount of out of focus illumination
as you can see here but if we do with a
two photon microscope only the point in
the focus would be illuminated any other
point in any other non focal plane would
not be illuminated that means we can get
resolution at very high level and that
confocality is not achieved here by
pinhole in confocal microscope though
there is some amount of out of focus
light it is cancelled out by the pinhole
at any point of time if you need to
learn about confocal you can click on
the i button but in two photon
microscope we don't have a pinhole we
don't need to use a pinhole because only
the points which are at focus would be
illuminated let me explain it in bit
more details
so here you illuminate the specimens
only these fluorescently level proteins
are at
focal plane so fluorescence would be
observed from them only any other
proteins which are not in the plane they
would not illuminate anything because
there they might experience these two
pulse of lasers in a time gap which is
more than 50 femtosecond that means they
are not really coinciding with each
other only the spots which are in focus
there the laser pulses would almost
coincide and
give rise to this two photon process
let's talk about the microscope
components and the light path in bit
more details so this is how a typical
fluorescent
two photon microscope would look like
lot of components together
but we should kind of like
disengage from this kind of view and
tell us that
two photon microscope could be highly
customizable it can look very different
but anyway here is a microscope body
there would be a laser unit which is
ultimately giving rise to the laser
there would be some stage controller
some fluorescence lamp just for locating
the specimen there would be a computer
system there would be other processing
units which kind of converts the analog
to digital information and send it to
the
computer so all of these things are
there anyway
the
laser is kind of tuned to emit something
720 nanometer to something
1500 nanometers of wavelength and the
powers are provided in this particular
graph in simple word this is known as
laser tuning curve for our two photon
laser
anyway you can see most of the cases
this laser is giving you red and far red
kind of illumination
now in two photon microscope
we can customize a lot of things so you
can see this microscope looks very
different from the previous one which is
kind of like a company or let's say a
company build microscope you can also
customize this microscope on your own by
adjusting the light paths so let us try
to understand the light path in bit more
details so again here in this diagram we
have our laser unit here so this laser
unit would actually give rise to a laser
which is generally invisible because it
is infrared but in this diagram we are
just pointing out
as a red laser
anyway this laser would pass through a
unit known as pockel cell this pockel
cell would actually reduce the laser
power because the laser power is in
order of what if we illuminate that much
of laser in a biological specimen it
would just fry out so obviously the
laser power need to tone down and that
is achieved by the pockel cell from the
pockel cell the laser moves through a
mirror array
and ultimately this mirror array guides
the laser towards the microscope body
behind the microscope there would be a
periscope that would allow the laser
beam to tran
to ascend up and ultimately through the
periscope it would enter the microscope
body
and ultimately there are other dichroic
scope and fill in the filter cube which
diverts this light or diverts this laser
through the objective into the specimen
now the fluorescent specimen would emit
fluorescence that is collected back
through the objective and it actually
hits the detector
and that is how a image is created so
now you can see the microscope is
scanning and forming a image of some
neurons
in the screen and that's how we can
image
it now let's talk about the applications
of two photon microscopy already you can
appreciate that with using two photon
microscopy we reduce the chances of
photo bleaching
now with a two photon microscopy it is
possible to image behaving animals in
real time scientists can really look at
what's going on inside a brain of an
animal
while they are performing a task
and that is why they need to design
custom build microscope like this one
shown here
so they can literally dig a hole in the
brain and they can inject some
fluorescent dyes or genetically encode
fluorescent calcium sensor by which they
can monitor the neuronal activity
and another advantage is two photon
microscope can literally image some
neurons or layer of neurons which are at
least
500 microns
deep from the surface
using a normal fluorescence microscope
we would never achieve this depth
everything would be bloody due to
scattering but we talked about how
scattering is taken care of in two
photon microscopy right higher the
wavelength lower the scattering that's
why deep tissue imaging can be done
using two photon microscopes that's the
biggest advantage
now let us understand how
neuroscientists use these two photon
microscope very frequently to monitor
neuronal activity they use a genetically
encoded calcium sensor which has a
calmodulin moiety which can ultimately
bind to the
bind to the calcium they have a
fluorescence protein gfp and a m13 helix
so when there is a calcium binding this
particular assembly leads to
fluorescence of gfp so fluorescence
readout gives us a readout
of calcium levels if the neuron is
active more calcium and it would give
rise to more fluorescence so monitoring
fluorescence level over time would give
us an idea about how neuronal activity
is changing
now there are certain calculations known
as delta f by f where they calculate a
fluorescence intensity at a given time
point
minus the initial fluorescence intensity
and normalize it with initial
fluorescence intensity this is a
characteristic
way of analyzing the fluorescence change
over time
and you can
do this for different different time
frames and later on create a movie to
understand how the neurons are firing
over time what are their firing dynamics
how the calcium dynamics is changing
over time for example scientists would
draw region of interest in these images
and calculate over time that would give
them traces like this
you can understand how four different
neurons are firing and how their firing
is similar or different
also scientists can do
certain analysis from this kind of
data they can understand whether the
network activity is synchronous versus
asynchronous on the right hand side you
can see the network activity is very
synchronous that means they are all
blinking and dimming together and that
leads to these kind of traces shown
below whereas in the left hand side you
can see there is an asynchronous
activity where the neurons are blinking
and they are not synced in time
all these things has different meaning
in terms of how our brain works and that
can be achieved by using a two photon
microscope there are many other
advantages of two photon microscope we
didn't discuss all of that in this
particular video but we only discussed
this part
anyway just to summarize we looked at
the principle of two photon microscopy
we looked at the components and the
light path of two photon microscopy
finally we talked about one usage of two
photon microscopy in neuroscience i hope
this was useful you can get further
notes in my facebook page but don't
forget to subscribe and hit that bell
icon you can also support my channel by
clicking on the super thanks button you
can contribute a little bit to my
channel that would your support means a
lot for me
anyway you can get notes and flash cards
in my facebook channel these dynamic
flash cards would really help you in
your preparation the link for facebook
channel is there in the description as
usual like share and subscribe you can
also